what's going on guys this is rob and i
recently realized there's a story where
thanos meets kang and it's kind of a
cool thing right so we covered the story
of infinity conflict a little while ago
and this is basically the prelude to
that so those of you guys who read or
who saw our videos on infinity conflict
you guys kind of know how this turns out
but it is a little bit of a cool thing
here right so this initially picks up
with thanos just kind of
re-experiencing we're kind of going
through all the various victories he's
experienced over the years and even
defeats his experience over the years
while he's in the realm of mistress
death now for those of you guys who
don't know when it comes to the to the
realm of mistress death and marvel
comics we've talked about this so those
of you guys who are familiar with this
just bear with me for a second while i
run over this for the new folks um
originally death didn't work this way in
marvel comics instead if you go back and
you look at the old stanley jack kirby
stories right tales of asgard all you
really had was the realm of hella and
that was basically it it wasn't until
the old iron man stories and the
introduction of mistress death and
thanos that you basically learned there
is a definitive afterlife for anybody
who doesn't follow like the asgardian
mythos basically and so following that
basically the role of mistress death is
where people go when they all just more
or less die right earthlings things like
that and then places like the realm of
mephisto or the realm of hella the realm
of satanish different things like that
are all kind of special circumstances
for people who barter certain deals or
different things along those lines but
for the longest time thanos was always
rebuked by mistress death and a lot of
you guys probably know that that he had
a kind of love interest in the form of
the fact that he was always pursuing the
affections of mistress death and she was
always shooting him down and so that was
kind of the cornerstone of him nihilism
things like that and there was actually
a point in marvel comics when he was
banned from the realm of mistress death
now that's where the infinity line of
stories sort of differentiate from the
main marvel universe and the reason why
is because the infinity gauntlet was a
landmark story was huge when it first
dropped and of course jim stalin
followed up with that with the infinity
war and the infinity crusade but the
infinity line of comics proved to be so
popular that marvel just gave him the
ability to write his own stories and so
following the events of infinity crusade
those stories largely became out of
continuity right so they don't
necessarily tie into the main marvel
universe and so you'll see events unfold
but they're all just kind of alternate
reality stories for example in the
aftermath of jonathan hickman's avengers
and new avengers secret wars the death
of the living tribunal in the infinity
stories adam warlock in an alternate
reality became the new living tribunal
now that was in continuity in marvel
comics only because the living tribunal
is a multiversal being so if somebody in
an alternate reality replaces him it's
basically the new living tribunal across
the entirety of the multiverse including
the main marvel universe but outside of
that everything else is basically out of
continuity and so with thanos kind of
reliving all these experiences and
coming to this realization that he
really seems to have everything he wants
that he's still not content and so he
kind of goes on this quest to really
kind of goes on a bit of a journey to
figure out what it is that leads him to
lack being content with his current
environment and so you switch over to
eros now those are guys who are not
familiar with comics eros is basically
the brother of uh of thanos that he also
goes by the name star fox and his
ability is to kind of you know emit
pheromones to basically get people to do
almost anything he wants especially to
kind of fall in love with him or to see
him as desirable that's why you
initially see him in bed with just like
five chicks
because that's kind of the thing of eros
he usually uses his powers in order to
get girls is is really what it is but in
the midst of him just kind of musing to
himself and sort of you know walking
around and so on and so forth he's
basically kind of whisked away through a
a kind of time portal and then on the
other side a new portal opens and you're
met with king the conqueror and a and
basically an unfamiliar individual now
following that as far as eros goes he's
kind of whisked away to a basically a
different point in time on a prehistoric
world and he's really just kind of
trying to escape as best he can and get
away from things but for thanos himself
basically he's met by corvus glaive one
of the uh the coal obsidian and he's
essentially told that a kind of temporal
disruption has emerged on titan and
that's interesting enough for thanos to
investigate right at the very least it's
hey look i can go do something now to
kind of fulfill this lack of contentment
that i have and essentially find out
what's going on here right and so when
he emerges on the scene he's basically
met by this kind of uh individual who is
who's kind of disappeared and kane the
conqueror who is basically left and so
with this cloaked individual he
basically reveals himself to be what is
in effect a future version of eros right
and so time travel of course is being
invoked here now one of the funny things
that goes on is that with kane the
conqueror when he had emerged he was
trying to stay away from thanos and the
reason why is because thanos is one of
these characters in marvel where he's
not easily killed more so than that if
thanos comes across you and realizes
you're not supposed to be there or that
you could offer some measure of him to
achieve a goal he's been setting out to
achieve he'll take you right he'll
conscript you or he'll kill you or
something along those lines but one of
the things to know is that thanos is
well beyond the power of kang the
conqueror and so there's not a whole lot
kane could do and facing off against
thanos not only that because thanos is
so wildly intelligent say for example
that kang were to appear at a previous
point in time then thanos would likely
deduce that kang had appeared to him at
a future point in time realized he
couldn't defeat him and so he came back
to a previous point to try to destroy
him and end up destroying kang right so
it's one of those things where thanos
intelligence is such a high level that
he can kind of figure things out pretty
quickly and so what you end up finding
out is that when this future version of
eros kind of starts telling a story
about why it is that he looks so old and
you know what was going on with him in
the future and so on and so forth he
reveals that one it's been two thousand
years since he and thanos saw each other
and that two uh he was basically in a
kind of exile for two thousand years you
know in a in on basically what was uh
this kind of world called zeltya and
that when he came here when he stumbled
across this world that he came across a
primitive race that tried to destroy him
and for the most part it was only
because of the fact that on this world
there's only three different races and
anybody who doesn't match that race they
kind of see him as basically an edible
animal right in the same way that we
would see like a deer or something like
that is something that we can hunt and
kill and so ultimately eros is saved by
one of the other races here and the
reason why they saved him is they
realize he had a ship right so he's not
necessarily of that world and so in turn
they were like you know you can probably
help us
at the very least help us to you know to
kind of win this conflict because these
three races are always at war with each
other and so as this bit of a story kind
of goes on you end up finding out that
this version of eros had basically
helped this race to achieve
i guess a higher state of enlightenment
with regards to weapons technology being
able to like evacuate their world using
ships and things like that so basically
ushered in a kind of technological
golden age for this particular race
right and in doing that kind of gave
them the tools they needed to evolve
beyond the stars to travel beyond the
stars that's incredibly important here
and the reason why is because what you
also end up finding out around that time
is that king the conqueror as he was
going through his you know timeline and
really the history of the universe
itself and always trying to expand his
empire came to the realization that at a
future point in time thanos would come
across a basically what he referred to
as a stygian darkness basically kind of
like a mysterious phenomena that
essentially encapsulated a world
traveled beyond that world into the
stars and then eventually fought thanos
and destroyed thanos and so the desire
of kane the conqueror is to essentially
keep that from happening and the reason
why is because any force out there
that's powerful enough to destroy thanos
especially in this higher state of
godhood that he seemed to have achieved
is a threat to the entirety of the
universe and by extension a threat to
the life of of king the conqueror
because remember when it comes the way
that jim stalin's writing this which
again is kind of out of continuity here
that if something affects the past it
can affect the future and so looking at
this the concern of kane the conqueror
is that if a organization or race uh
basically conquered the universe at that
point in time then it's entirely
possible it could spread outward and
because it seems like it's not supposed
to exist somebody had meddled with time
and in turn caused this whole thing in
the first place and so the desire of
kang is to ensure that it doesn't spread
beyond the stars and it doesn't spread
throughout the entirety of the time
stream and in turn basically destroy
king's empire and even control kang
himself and so tracing this back to his
genesis point kang believed that it all
started on a planet named zeltya with
people that had the ability to teleport
basically this race that eros had come
across uh while he was essentially
exiled and the desire of kang was to
basically kill this first teleporter and
then in turn stop that from happening
the problem is that it didn't work that
throughout the time stream this always
kept on happening that this this you
know stygian darkness this kind of
powerful entity out there kept showing
up again and again and again and there
came a point where kane got so close to
it that it almost consumed him and so in
a panic he basically sent his ship
flying through the time stream with no
definitive arrival point and he
ultimately stumbled across this barren
world 2000 years into the future which
basically housed eros where he had
basically been defeated and kind of
removed and exiled to that planet and by
the two of them working together they
ultimately cultivated a plan that was
designed for the purpose of eros coming
back here and trying to find a way to
work with thanos to stop that stitching
and darkness from happening and so the
way this plan the the plan of the two of
them concoct is that at the end of the
day the the race on that planet zelchia
is gonna have to go right because of the
fact that it all originates from there
that essentially they're going to put
together at least as far as the the plan
that kang and eros had formed that
thanos would assemble what is in effect
a small little contingent team and they
would in turn travel to this world and
they would basically lay waste to all
life on it and that in doing so it
should stop that stygian darkness from
arriving here now as far as the version
of eros goes that had been thrown into
the past much like the future version of
himself he had kind of given this race
weaponry taught them technology all
kinds of different things the ability to
travel into space and so the hope here
is that in doing that they would
basically present themselves as a more
intelligent and capable organism and
that the hope is that if thanos truly
dies in the future that because this
race is gonna basically has their
evolution kind of jump started by eros
and basically giving them advanced
technologies which partially come from
the shia empire they would be able to
help thanos quell that threat in the
future and that in doing so thanos is
basically not going to destroy eros
he can return to his own timeline and
essentially not be destroyed or kind of
uh exiled at some future point in time
the problem with all this is that in
both of these scenarios they basically
solidify what's going on with the
stygian darkness that this this race
gaining interstellar travel by way of
eros is really what causes all this and
the reason why is because one of the
members of this race who's here is
basically met by the cause of the
stitching and darkness right the cause
of this kind of walking death that
exists out there and this person comes
in the form of a being called hunger now
those of you guys who are familiar with
jim starlin's whole story with hunger
and all that kind of stuff
um this is one of those concepts where
comic book fans either think it's cool
or they hate it and for the most part
the only people who really liked it were
die hard jim starlin fans everybody else
was like this is ridiculous
this basically sucks uh the whole thing
behind this is that hunger was basically
an extra dimensional being that
basically latched itself on to to
galactus and it was kind of jim
starlin's way of saying this is why
galactus desires to consume everything
because he's actually possessed by being
called hunger ultimately it was defeated
and largely believed to have been
destroyed the reality is that it's
returned here and the way this
explanation is given to us is that at
some point because of the fact that
hunger came from an extra-dimensional
space it had kind of been manipulating
things the entire time and that entering
into this realm that it needed a source
of energy to basically achieve this so
it basically rode the infinity stones
into this new reality bonded itself to
galactus and then in turn when galactus
and thanos fought that when it was
believed that hunger was destroyed a
small piece of it survived left galactus
and then traveled throughout the the
universe trying to find a suitable host
to bond itself to and that's when it
arrived on this world and bonded itself
to this this you know one of these three
races and then in turn wrote itself into
the future and then ultimately ended up
conquering and destroying thanos right
so this is the actual darkness that
everybody or really that kang and all
those guys were essentially concerned
about and so the other part of this is
that what you end up getting is thanos
who's essentially whisked away into
what's referred to as elsewhere but it's
really more of a far-flung future and
he's kind of met by this you know kind
of disembodied voice that basically
tells him that what's going to happen
here with regards to everything taking
place with with eros and all that kind
of stuff then in the end it is all still
going to result in thanos dying no
matter what plan they implement here
that hunger is going to spread
throughout the universe and it is going
to kill thanos and that ultimately
hunger will consume all things and so in
order to keep that from happening the
plan of eros and kang is not going to
work and so another plan needs to be
manufactured here the problem with this
is that if eros for example is killed
it'll basically lead to a paradox in the
time stream and so what ends up
happening is thanos kind of shows up
here on the scene and basically ends up
encountering his brother eros when he
shows up at this point in the timeline
and so arriving here eros is basically
attacked by thanos who basically you
know seems to more or less kill him and
then just throw him out into the middle
of nowhere and so following that because
of the fact that the only way to
basically keep that future from
happening where the universe is
conquered by by hunger and everybody is
eradicated is for thanos to wipe out the
entirety of this race and this is
appealing to thanos because as you guys
know thanos loves the concept of death
and thanos loves to destroy all things
that exist and so this basically leads
to thanos kind of amassing a fleet based
on the new plan that was created between
himself and this disembodied voice that
was talking to him the person that we
don't see and they basically eradicate
everything here which is the other
reason why eros was basically killed by
thanos and so in the midst of all of
this right like with these members of
these races basically evacuating based
on the ships that were given to them by
eros this whole plan of thanos and this
future version doesn't necessarily work
out the way that they intended and so
this conversation between thanos and his
future self basically continues when you
end up finding out that it's basically
revealed to thanos that even though he
was believed to have been successful
even though he thought he had killed
enough members of this race at the end
of the day it doesn't matter right the
true architect of this whole stitching
and darkness will basically arrive and
in turn he'll end up conscripting what's
left of this race across the universe
into his army and that at the end of the
day thanos will still die and so
ultimately the only real way to stop
this is to actually go after that source
itself and so this leads to thanos
eventually tracking down hunger and then
annihilating hunger right destroying
this this bit of an entity here now of
course hunger tries to possess thanos
and it doesn't necessarily work out that
way instead thanos manages to destroy
hunger entirely and that basically
brings it into that and so following
that you basically find that because
future eros is alive that means that
eros in the past was not actually
destroyed that instead it was kind of a
paralytic effect that was imposed on him
by thanos and his body was just kind of
thrown into the lake and then that was
basically it and that it was really more
of a distraction than anything else all
for the purpose of solidifying this plan
more so than that you end up having kane
the conqueror that just kind of appears
here and then is met by the arrival of
thanos right and the whole point was
that thanos was meeting with king for
this idea that in solidifying the
destruction of this particular of really
hunger itself that now kang is in the
debt of thanos and so in turn the the
question kang has is then what do we do
here and thanos response is like what
are you looking for i've destroyed this
guy like what all do you want out of me
or what are you looking to achieve and
the idea is that kang really simply just
wants to rule a section of the universe
for himself write a section of the
multiverse for himself and that thanos
will leave him that section right
because thanos is destined to achieve
this level of godhood that's basically
what kang says i know what your future
is going to be i know what you're going
to look like i know the level of power
you're going to achieve and when that
time comes what i ask is that you allow
me to rule my little section here and
you basically leave me alone right
because at the end of the day if that
doesn't happen thanos will end up
destroying kang so if anything it's
really just self-preservation and so
ultimately the response to thanos is
fine i will do that but you will owe me
a debt right like you owe me a debt here
in order for me to allow you to to kind
of rule your own section and then in
turn the the whole thing here is thanos
basically says like you will basically
travel to the year 4027 and you'll wait
in orbit above chandelard and then in
turn you'll be met with orders and
you'll be told what to do and so that
all that really does is kind of solidify
thanos's role here right the the fact
that he is in effect going to become his
future counterpart now when you switch
over to this quote unquote elsewhere
discussion you end up basically finding
out the whole story is more or less told
in hindsight and all this is done for
the purpose of solidifying what thanos
will become that there does come a
future point in time when thanos
basically becomes the universe itself
now it actually goes beyond that right
when he attains the astral regulator
which again is the whole idea behind
infinity conflict and he basically
imbues himself with everything right he
becomes like he takes over the living
tribunal he contribute he absorbs the
one above all he takes over mistress
death the whole nine yards right like he
becomes what is in effect the entirety
of god and the whole basis behind this
story of everything that's happened was
done for the purpose of ensuring as far
as that future thanos goes that his
existence actually is maintained right
that nothing gets in the way and nothing
stops that more so than that because
hunger was seemingly this universe-wide
credible threat and the only thing that
really seemed to be powerful enough to
actually stop uh astral regulator thanos
that this is now quelled and it's out of
the picture and it's done and so
basically there's no one standing in the
way of astro regulator thanos becoming
this most powerful version of himself
what's going on guys this is rob and a
lot of you guys have requested that i
make a video on astral regulator thanos
specifically like the um like a beyond
omega level video and honestly i didn't
know
who that like i didn't know what version
of thanos that was because if i'm being
honest with you guys i have not really
followed jim starlin's infinity saga
after the events of like infinity
crusade right like i finished that and i
was kind of like okay cool i'm kind of
done and that was that was basically it
i know he's written a lot right like
infinity siblings and infinity
revelations and infinity war relativity
and all that i know he's done all that
and we'll go back and cover those things
because some of those stories are cool
others are not but i think it'd be kind
of cool to just sort of have the whole
infinity series on my channel so we'll
probably cover like relativity or
revelations or something like that after
this but you know i i sat down and i was
like okay what in the heck is astral
regulator thanos and i looked it up and
i was like okay so like i have to cover
this story because this story is kind of
nuts right now here's the funny thing
about it as i understand it this is what
the thanos wins story was originally
intended to be by jim starlin right he
was the one who wanted to write it that
when donnie kate wrote that story jim
starlin wanted to be the one to create
it because jim starlin was the one that
did so much with the character of thanos
and so the results of this is that as we
know thanos wins was a story that was
written you know by donnie kate's and so
eventually marvel ended up releasing
this and if i'm being honest with you
guys there's good things about this
story and things that i wasn't really
huge on but there was the same thing
with thanos wins right there were things
that i loved about it things i didn't
really that i wasn't too big on it i
think if both of these stories were
combined it would be amazing it would be
absolutely ridiculously good because of
all the things that go down here right
but the way that this kicks off is we
initially pick up with thanos meeting
with adam warlock now this comes hot off
the heels of infinity gauntlet is really
where this little segment of this story
comes from in the sense that those are
the guys who followed my series on
infinity gauntlet and infinity war and
if you didn't you'll find both those
down in the description infinity
gauntlet of course as most of you guys
know is a story where thanos discovered
and then started using the infinity
gauntlet and seized control of the
universe and then ultimately lost it to
nebula an infinity war or really the
aftermath kind of a segue between the
two so it was more of a i guess like a
prelude it was part of warlock and the
infinity watch going into infinity war
itself the living tribunal basically
decreed that adam warlock had to
disperse the stones right the stones
would no longer work in unison the
gauntlet itself wouldn't work anymore
and warlock had to basically find people
who were capable of wielding the stones
but not using them in order to keep them
protected by in order to make sure that
nobody could reassemble them together
again which seemed like a moot point
because even if they were assembled
nobody could use them but people could
still use the the individual stones
hence the reason for the infinity watch
and so during that time we ended up
learning in infinity war that thanos was
in possession of the reality stone and
we didn't initially know that right we
didn't know who who warlock gave the
reality stone to but in this this little
segment here is designed to kind of fill
in that little bit of a gap right
because during infinity war it was like
and then thanos got the got the reality
stone and that was basically it and this
is designed to kind of fill in the gaps
and essentially say that that thanos was
the one who was most suitable to wield
it right because only thanos could
really comprehend the power of the
reality stone and be able to maintain
that kind of discipline right because
with this stone in your possession even
your most subconscious desires become
reality you could fall asleep and dream
of like the grudge and then like she
manifests because of the reality stone
and then kills you right so like any
number of those things could could
happen if thanos was really the only guy
who could maintain that and so what this
does is it picks up you know kind of
right now in the modern day and what it
does is it kind of gives us this idea
that adam warlock feels as though
something's off in the universe right
something's just not quite right there's
some kind of imminent danger coming now
this is part and parcel to the powers of
adam warlock in the sense that he really
is very much a sort of you know
jesus-esque character in marvel right he
dies and he's reborn over and over and
over again he can never truly be killed
he'll always end up coming back in some
form or fashion at the same time he also
kind of has this cosmic awareness and
through his experience with the soul
stone is also sort of partly partial to
the universe now how deep reaching this
goes and exactly what this means on like
a definitive concrete level jim
sterling's never really explained right
it's almost like the the white phoenix
of the crown and like her role in the
multiverse why she just fixes things
that are broken whatever in the hell
that means and so with adam warlock a
lot of it's kind of the same way it's
pretty ambiguous and it really just sort
of allows marvel and jim starlin to kind
of have a blank slate in terms of what
they want to do with this character and
so on and so forth but ultimately he
ends up basically traveling alongside
pip the troll to go see thanos right
this is a really cool moment here
because with pip the troll of course
he's a long-standing member of the
infinity watch a long-standing friend of
warlock the two of them have been
together for quite some time but
traveling and seeing thanos is really
one of the first acts of warlock for a
couple reasons right the first thing is
something seems off and thanos might
know something but the other part of
this is the two of them have a very
lengthy relationship they've been
on-again off-again allies more so than
that there's a huge amount of respect
between the two and so as adam warlock
begins talking to thanos and saying like
you know there's some kind of dramatic
change that's coming there's a kind of
approaching darkness it's a cool moment
because thanos kind of chimes in and
basically says yes you know there is a
kind of darkness approaching and he
kills adam warlock
he's like i am that darkness and right
off the bat thanos destroys adam warlock
like literally incinerates his entire
body pip the troll teleports the hell
out he's like man this is wild peace and
like bales and then thanos is just like
take the body and dispose of it done and
so like from there you pick up on the
planet chandelar two weeks later
chandelar of course being the home of
the shiar empire with adam warlock
basically re-emerging after this
two-week period then the question is
what in the heck is going on right like
why did thanos kill me now adam warlock
doesn't immediately suspect that thanos
is of some kind of like terrible
horrible nefarious plot he believes he's
doing some pretty shady stuff but he
really wants to get more to the bottom
of things and to figure out what's
happening the problem with this is that
once pip the troll locates thanos and
then teleports him and adam warlock to
it adam warlock gets blown up by a
missile
he immediately gets destroyed by a
missile and the response to thanos is
like like when he's talking to his black
order it's like you know yes you know
adam warlock will come back but all we
have to do is kill him three times after
that it won't matter and so what he ends
up doing is basically traveling to this
particular location this this particular
artifact looking for a kind of puzzle of
sorts and the reason why really kind of
ties into infinity siblings and the
sense of what you had in that story is
you had a future version of thanos that
basically ended up meeting with his
younger self and what this this future
version of thanos is doing is basically
guiding younger thanos to some kind of
end goal but he never actually told him
what the end goal was it was just you
have to do these things in order to get
to this point where i'm at and so thanos
is in a lot of ways blindly following
the orders of his future self under the
idea that one he knows himself so he
trusts himself and two there's going to
be some kind of grand payoff or
something along the way so the results
of this is that once thanos basically
accesses this particular artifact and
learns of this kind of of map of sorts
you know this particular location that
it's sending him to of course he gets
back aboard his ship and then ultimately
we end up picking up with star fox now
star fox or eros is the brother of
thanos so a lot of you guys probably
know that by now the two of them have a
very very lengthy history infiniti
siblings really push that history in
that relationship to the extreme but
it's one of these things where it's kind
of like okay eros has a couple a couple
tools at his disposal the first one is
that he basically utilized the time
traveling technology of king the
conqueror and the reason why was during
the events of infinity siblings kang
came to the realization that somewhere
along the line thanos dies and when that
happens he ultimately ends up dragging
the entirety of the multiverse down with
the death of thanos triggers a cascading
effect that brings everything to an end
prematurely so the idea was that thanos
has to live and so uh kane the conqueror
basically orchestrated all these
different events to to ensure that right
so kind of a spoiler for a video that
we're going to cover later on but the
long and short of this is that heroes
had stolen some of the technology of
kang in order to ensure that should
something happen where thanos engages in
some kind of nefarious plot that eros
can go back in time and correct it the
other part of this is that a device has
basically been created this exceedingly
small this also based on the technology
of kang that can be used to essentially
track thanos right because eros does not
have that inherent ability the next
thing that really happens here is a new
form of manifestation from adam warlock
usually adam warlock's body always kind
of enters a cocoon state and adam
warlock comes back what ends up
happening here is that some guy ends up
falling off a cliff and that person is
then suddenly encased in a cocoon and
then after a two-week period adam
warlock re-emerges right so basically
this random being was re-materialized
into adam warlock and then adam warlock
return this is not normal it doesn't
usually happen and there is in fact a
force behind everything pulling the
strings when it comes to adam warlock
there's a reason why all this is
happening with him and so what it does
from here is it basically picks up with
with eros you know ultimately tracking
down thanos and it's kind of this cool
little little moment here because thanos
of course is looking for eros under the
guise that his future self informed him
that eros will become very important
with regards to the various goals that
they want to achieve and so while thanos
cannot kill eros what he has to do is
essentially find him and then keep him
contained so that he can be used at a
future point in time what that use is
going to be and the role that eros is
going to play of course we'll find out
at some point
you know we'll end up finding out in
this story but you know from there of
course hero's communicating with isaac
isaac of course being the computer of
titan the one that basically kind of
governs the whole society and so on ends
up using this tracking device puts it on
thanos and then makes himself intangible
now the way it is that eros does this is
by manipulating time and it's a little
bit of a weird thing when it comes to
the notion of phasing in and out of
reality technically speaking the way
this works is that marvel kind of seems
to adopt this mentality of like things
travel in like one second chunks right
so like if you were one second ahead of
me i wouldn't be able to see you but if
you're a fraction of a second ahead of
me then it means that like you're kind
of this intangible being that i cannot
truly see but you kind of exist in that
same moment i mean because that that
fraction of time is so astronomically
small right so i don't know if that
really makes any sense you know but it's
it's one of those one of those weird
things right like imagine the time it
takes for you to turn your head around
and that's really what this is
equivalent to right like it takes you
you know if you were to snap your head
back you know it would take you maybe
like one and a half seconds to do but
like in that one and a half second
period you've also got exceedingly
shorter amounts of time fractions of a
second and what marvel's doing here
really what jim starlin is doing here is
introducing this idea that eros's
ability to manipulate time is such that
it's not putting him seconds ahead of
thanos is putting him fractions of a
second ahead of thanos which means he's
essentially in the same moment that
thanos is in but because he's kind of
out of phase meaning he's fractions of a
second ahead thanos cannot really see
him right it's one of these weird things
right like how can you interact with
something that doesn't know you're there
when you're technically not there it's
weird and it's really finicky i
understand if you're totally baffled and
totally confused it's just one of those
plot points that marvel creates in order
to achieve a certain goal and so what
ends up happening here is of course adam
warlock and pip end up tracking down
thanos and once they arrive thanos has
already left the area but then of course
they end up arriving and meeting with
eros and this is a very welcome ally
given the history between these
characters the fact that eros has
consistently worked to thwart the
schemes of thanos right so their allies
in that regard and bringing to bear this
information that eros has put a tracking
device on thanos in order to locate him
and he also has the ability to
manipulate time is a cool little thing
because it means it's basically they're
out if they choose or have the
opportunity to use it the other part of
this is that as they're talking adam
warlock gets hit with a missile again
it just comes out of nowhere and just
hits him and then adam warlock is of
course destroyed right that's the end of
that now pip the troll ends up
teleporting away but basically it's one
of these things where pip and and uh in
heroes have this conversation of hey
like we have our chance to basically
combine our information and to figure
out what this bigger picture is right
it's kind of like the illuminati effect
that using their information that they
become greater than the sum of their
parts and so from there you end up
seeing thanos more or less being
teleported away and encountering his
future self now this future version of
thanos is amazing looking right like he
looks like eternity with the face of
mistress death like i don't know it's
kind of wild like having him look this
way it looks kind of crazy but he looks
like a cosmic entity so the question is
how did thanos achieve this level of
power and the way in which he gets to
that point is actually pretty solid
because what this does is it basically
leads to thanos and his future self
having this conversation now his future
self is again pretty ambiguous here
again it's that conversation eros is
going to be important you can't kill him
you have to capture him you have to hold
on to him so on and so forth but you
also have a tracking device on you right
so like make sure you get rid of that so
eros cannot find you that kind of a
thing ultimately because eros is aligned
with pip and because pip has the ability
to track thanos no matter where he is
doesn't really matter at all but what we
end up having here is is basically
future thanos and what passes for
present-day thanos concluding their
conversation and then you end up having
eeros and pip the troll of course
teleport to thanos's location and when
they get there this planet the planet
zelchia i think is what it is the last
time eeros was here during the events of
infinity siblings the place was a very
lush and welcome environment right it
was beautiful it was like a giant
rainforest very tropical and gorgeous
something seems to have happened here
that laid waste to the entire location
and so when the question is like have
you teleported us to the wrong place the
response is no like this entire place
has basically been totally annihilated
or totally destroyed and what you have
here is that this location has been
transformed into the realm of mistress
death that's what this is now right it's
the realm of death which is really kind
of weird because mistress death does not
occupy a physical plane she doesn't
really exist on any one particular
physical planet right you can't get on a
spaceship and fly to the realm of
mistress death she exists as an other
dimensional entity she literally exists
in the afterlife right so i mean i guess
you could you could get on a ship and
fly to the afterlife if the ship
explodes or like flies into a star and
you die then sure you can get to the
afterlife but you can't physically go
there i mean i guess you can if you can
manipulate dimensional barriers like
doctor strange or somebody like that or
like thanos but what it does is it
switches back over to thanos and him
basically just sort of sitting in space
and where corvus glaive and the
outriders don't really know why he's
there they don't really know what's
going on like like what they're waiting
for thanos's response is i've been
informed that at this point there's
going to be an object or a device
passing through here and my job is to
take it and so it's kind of like okay
like we'll see how this goes which is
kind of wild and ultimately it ends up
being a comet that flies through there
now thanos of course ends up traveling
to the comet by himself and this is an
interesting thing because it's not just
any regular comet the more important
thing to come out of this is that thanos
states whatever this object is and he
basically says it's power of a magnitude
exceeding that of the infinity gems
right so whatever this object is it's
way beyond the power of the infinity
stones which really of course interests
thanos because he's always been on a
quest to attain absolute power the
problem with this is that the device
hidden inside of the object hidden
inside this this comet is not something
that can just be arbitrarily attained
right i mean you know it's not like you
know it was created and then just
dropped off on earth somewhere and like
it's just been sitting in a convenience
store it can't be one of those things
where just anybody can get their hands
on it that there's all kinds of power
protecting it you know like this kind of
cosmic energy source and so thanos of
course starts ripping it apart starts
pulling it away and in the process he
himself begins undergoing disintegration
his body starts breaking down the power
is really more than his physical form
can handle which really speaks volumes
to how much power we're talking about
here because the kind of energy that's
needed to physically damage thanos is
astronomical really what happens here is
once he breaks through to the core of
this comet and he secures this object
for himself then what it appears to be
is this kind of orb of sorts now we'll
find out exactly what this is and what
is what it's able to do but from there
thanos when he kind of muses and asks
the question you're like i'm not really
even sure what this is for myself of
course this future version just kind of
seems to appear to thanos and it says
it's both a promise and a mystery take
this thing and use it and i promise all
your questions will be answered and so
what it does is it leads to thanos
showing up to the realm of mistress
death and of course as soon as he
arrives here thanos is told you cannot
be here and that's the way it usually is
right thanos has been banned from the
realm of mistress death for quite some
time right he's not really welcome here
and the thing about him showing up is
he's really kind of amusing and saying
like for all the people who tell me that
i cannot come here which of you is going
to stop me right how many times have i
come in here and mistress death says i
can't be here and then she sends some
force after me and then i totally
destroy it who's gonna stop me are you
guys gonna stop me and thanos of course
annihilates all the henchmen and the
various people that are there to prevent
him from staying in the realm of
mistress death they're all completely
destroyed and then thanos begins
speaking directly to death herself and
says how many times have you spurned my
advances how many times have i made my
affections known to you and you've
rejected me how many times has that
happened well nevertheless if i cannot
possess then i shall become and using
this object thanos transfers the energy
into mistress death pulls her into
himself eradicates mistress death
entirely and thanos himself becomes the
new death in the last video we basically
kind of had this idea where you
essentially had like future thanos right
and thanos in this future looked like
eternity but whatever it was that
happened to him he seemingly became this
like omnipotent sort of character the
idea behind this is that that modern day
thanos is more or less being guided by
future thanos so we'll kind of get an
answer to that question a sort of
explanation as to what's going on but
with eros the brother of thanos and pip
the troll trying to figure out what
thanos is doing and then in turn trying
to find a way to defeat him they've
essentially just been following him
throughout what he's been doing right so
the idea was that thanos had essentially
managed to find some way to acquire a
particular artifact a particular device
called the the astral regulator or the
cosmic regulator and then destroyed
mistress death and really like absorbed
her essence into himself and then became
the new death basically meaning that
thanos now controls the realm of the
afterlife and so where he essentially
teleports away eros and pip the troll
follow him but they don't know exactly
where he's going the best they can do is
just kind of jump forward through time
using their device taken by kane the
conqueror and then just try to
understand what it is that's happening
right so this is really just guess and
check and so what they do is jump a year
into the future and when they arrive
here in the future galactus ship had
basically just kind of crash landed in
this realm and when they start
inspecting they start looking around
they basically come to the realization
that thanos has been exceedingly busy
that not only did thanos destroy and
absorb galactus thanos has also absorbed
the infinity stones he's absorbed master
order lord chaos the stranger sire hate
mistress love he basically absorbed all
the cosmic entities into himself and
he's been busy now all this happened off
panel i'm not really skipping over
anything we literally go from one page
to this page he's basically just been
absorbing all the cosmic entities into
himself but the reality of where eros
and pip the troll are is that it's just
kind of like all right so there's not a
whole lot we can do here right like in
the present moment right now there's
nothing we can do to defeat thanos like
we're gonna have to find a way to go
back in time and to basically keep this
from happening now here's here's the
cool thing before you bounce jim
stoneman plays time exceedingly smart in
this story he does it in a really really
cool way and that's one of the things
that a lot of writers kind of run into
one of the problems they run into bendis
ran into that problem when it came to
matthew malloy different writers run
into time travel with different problems
and more often than not it's usually
invoked as a means to end the story jim
starlin passes that and basically copes
with it in spectacular fashion but the
cool thing about this is that adam
warlock you know where you end up having
pip the troll and uh and eros who
basically kind of jump forward and
continue their journey and figuring out
what the end game of thanos is adam
warlock is resurrected and one of the
things that we had talked about in the
last video is that adam warlock coming
back the way that he did was kind of
abnormal it didn't always happen that
way that he always kind of had a
particular form and function right like
a cocoon would manifest somewhere and
adam warlock would start to regenerate
inside of it and then ultimately he
would come out he'd make his presence
known and whatever story was going on
that required him to be in that event
what was going on here were things like
it was a resurrection process that
wasn't normal right and so what this
meant was that adam warlock didn't know
entirely what was going on and so when
he basically hops back up and really
kind of asks the question what's going
on with these changes in my resurrection
process he's met by the arrival of the
living tribunal and the living tribunal
basically says i'm the one behind all
this like i'm the reason why you're
resurrecting the way that you are now
one of the funny things about this is
that when adam warlock starts asking
questions like okay well what's going on
like like you know why am i here that
kind of a thing the living tribunal says
like we're outside of reality but like
you are outside of the norm now there's
a very particular meaning to that and we
will find out what that meaning is later
on in this video but the two of them get
in a very in-depth discussion and the
reason why is because of course you have
a living tribunal kind of like is this
multiversal overseer right so even if
the living tribunal can be destroyed his
job is to watch the multiverse and to
safeguard it as best he can and so
there's nothing that takes place inside
of a universe across the entirety of the
multiverse that the living tribunal
doesn't know about whether or not he can
stop it is a whole different argument
but he's always aware of everything
that's happening right so multiversal
awareness it's part and parcel to his
role but of course adam warlock also
addresses the idea of the living
tribunal this version is basically an
alternate reality version of adam
warlock those of you guys who recall
that in the aftermath of jonathan
hickman's avengers and new avengers and
secret wars when the living tribunal and
all the cosmic entities were destroyed
jim starlin wrote an infinity comic that
was a tie into it all more or less it
was kind of a loose event but the notion
was uh the one above all needed a new
living tribunal since the beyonders
destroyed the previous one and so adam
warlock from an alternate reality was
made into the new living tribunal so
that's just kind of a quick 30 second or
a minute explanation but as to the
astral regulator and as as to how it is
thanos has this level of power this all
basically comes through an explanation
from the living tribunal and this is a
really really cool concept introduced by
uh by jim starlin it's actually built on
something else right so for the longest
time when it came to the multiverse in
marvel jim starlin had introduced
different things like the custodian of
the multiverse and so on and so forth
but the idea here is that we of course
have an infinite number of universes out
there the question that we always sort
of asked here is what keeps one universe
from crossing over into another what jim
starling gives us here is the astral
regulator and what he says is that in
every single universe that exists out
there there is an astro regulator right
every universe exists for every
possibility but the living tribunal
chimes in and says the astral regulators
are basically there to ensure that no
universe crosses over into another this
is in fact jim starlin's adaptation of
dc's source wall that's more or less
what this is right the idea that the
source wall that every universe has its
own source wall then the multiverse has
its own source wall and these are
literal barriers around universes and
around the multiverse that are designed
to prevent universes from crossing over
into other universes and multiverses
from crossing over into other
multiverses jim starlin is essentially
taking that idea and rolling it over and
basically saying the astral regulator is
designed for the purpose of ensuring
that no universe crosses over into
another but it's a very complex network
right and so essentially thanos taking
it has kind of destabilized things and
again we'll talk more about that here in
a little bit but what the living
tribunal tells adam warlock is thanos is
working towards the notion of not
conquering the universe as we saw him do
an infinity gauntlet it's not like that
where he's getting the infinity stones
slapping him on a glove and then
basically replacing eternity thanos is
going for something much much grander
thanos is trying to become the entirety
of reality and that's why future thanos
looks the way he does he looks like
eternity because that future version of
thanos seemingly has achieved that level
of power he is all that is he's all in
existence and so the result of this is
is you basically have the tribunal
tasking adam warlock with the idea of
being the person that's going to
essentially find a way to defeat thanos
now in truth a lot of people could
probably undertake this role but jim
starlin chose adam warlock because the
entirety of the infinity line of stories
going from infinity gauntlet all the way
up to this story and really infinity
ending ties into the idea that there's
just something unique and special about
thanos and adam warlock now again adam
warlock outside the norm we'll kind of
cover that here in a little bit but they
are indeed wholly unique characters they
are indeed characters where for the most
part yes they exist in different
realities but they stand away from
everybody else right they stand separate
from everybody else insofar as how they
compare to like all the doctor stranges
and all the cyclopses and all the
captain americas and all the spider-mans
and all the wolverines and and phoenix
forces and so on and so forth and so
what this does is it basically leads to
this idea that adam warlock has to do
something in order to defeat thanos and
so he's kind of tasked by the tribunal
since he's really the only one that can
seemingly pull this off now picking back
up with eros and pip the troll they kind
of do this jumping around the universe
right they end up jumping into the
future a little bit further and they hop
skip and around the universe they go by
earth they go by all these different
places the space station or the
celestial head of nowhere the planet of
mord the planet of spartax the brood
world a scroll outpost rigel all these
different places they've all been
destroyed by thanos right like all life
has been totally eradicated by thanos
like even down to the microscopic level
nothing exists there anymore and so what
this does is it picks up with a loving
tribunal meeting with the one above all
now we never get to see this in marvel
comics we never really see what happens
when the living tribunal meets with the
one above all that usually never ever
ever happens and in fact as far as i'm
aware this is the first time in marvel
comics we've actually gotten to see the
two of them converse in this capacity
usually it's the living tribunal saying
something like i represent a power
that's beyond everything or whatever it
is you know he's just super op beyond
beyond omega level is what he is but the
one above all basically tells the living
tribunal what's going on in this one
universe threatens all of creation right
it threatens all things in existence
what's happened here is threatening
everything now one of the cool things
that goes on is the one above all's face
shifts he changes from one one race to
another to another to another and so
it's kind of a cool thing to kind of see
this melding and switching and changing
that the one above all is not a finite
construct right like he's just kind of
this representation of everything that
exists out there and what the one above
all says is this astral regulator is
designed to regulate the entirety of the
multiverse that it's not as small beings
as the living tribunal thought it was
right the living tribunal looked at this
and said okay so basically thanos taking
the astral regulator creates a cosmic
imbalance and my job is to enforce that
and because he's kind of outside the
norm and he has a level of power and so
on and so forth adam warlock you go take
care of it what the one above all says
is no you fail to grasp the complexity
of this now this is super important
because it hits this idea that despite
all of his vaunted power the living
tribunal is not an immutable all-knowing
force right like he's basically he's
screwed up here it's really what it is
right he misjudged he misunderstood the
complexity and how extreme the situation
is what the one above all says is the
astral regulator of each universe yes
they exist their purpose is to keep a
universe from crossing over with another
but the truth of this is that they're
all tied into a network so what's
basically gone on here is thanos is
playing a giant game of jenga and he's
starting to pull out the wrong pieces
and it's only a matter of time before
this whole thing comes crashing down by
taking this astral regulator and pulling
it away from his role and then
repurposing it for the for the reason of
giving himself omnipotence he's upset
the multiversal balance right the
balance of all existence not only that
what he's doing can actually happen he
could become the entirety of reality
itself in essence the one above all now
views thanos as a credible threat and
that's what's so crazy about this right
thanos is at a level of power now for
the one above all is legitimately
concerned and at the end of the day it
all comes down to adam warlock to be the
one to pull it off and so that's why all
these things are really sort of crazy
here that's why it's so chaotic it's
because what we do is we basically jump
to you know present day thanos for lack
of a better word who's absorbed all
these cosmic entities meeting with his
future self right the one that is
essentially merged with all of reality
and the whole reason behind this is the
fact that future thanos is is fearful of
the fact that somebody will figure out
what he's doing and basically stop his
younger self and that's the cool thing
here right this is jim solomon playing
it smart with reality that we would look
at this and we would say okay so if
present-day thanos is talking to his
future self and his future self becomes
a connected to all all of reality he
becomes everything in existence
presumably you know transcending the one
above all in the living tribunal and all
that then like why would he concern
himself with like making sure his
younger self gets there and the reason
why is because anybody could screw it up
at any point in time it's one thing to
achieve that role but the reality of
what thanos has learned with regards to
the multiverse is the fact that there's
an infinite number of realities out
there and anything can happen somebody
can pop up they can be at the right
place at the right time and so it's
essentially guiding himself right making
sure that like the things that could get
in his way don't get in his way right
that just because he ended up in this
future you know and became this being
doesn't mean that it's guaranteed right
like if for example he was supposed to
kill adam warlock at a particular point
in time and he didn't everything gets
thrown off and any number of things can
cause that to happen right any number of
things can can get in there and so what
you do is you pick up basically with
eros and with uh with pip the troll kind
of coming to this conclusion is it's
sort of a red herring here the way jim
sterling plays it because it's like okay
so like they're gonna go back in time
they're gonna kill thanos and he's a
baby and basically stop the future okay
so like this is like and and there are
some writers out there who would say and
this is how we end the story guys thanks
for watching you know jim starlin does
this and before eros can pull it off
adam warlock pops up and says if you do
that nothing will happen this not going
to work because what's going to happen
here is things are going to be worse and
this is really jim stalin tying in to
everything he's done with regards to
adam warlock and thanos and the entire
infiniti series right the relationship
between the two and when jim stalin was
writing the old adam warlock comics the
relationship between adam warlock and
thanos was that thanos had actually come
to the aid of adam warlock and helping
adam defeat his own future evil
counterpart the magus you know magus
attempt to basically gain the the
infinity gauntlet for himself during the
events of infinity war thanos being part
of warlock in the infinity watch and
basically having the reality stone and
then giving a false stone to uh the
magus is what led to magus defeat at the
end of the whole thing right he had an
affinity gauntlet but he wasn't all
powerful because he didn't have all the
infinity stones what adam says here is
that if eros kills thanos as a baby then
it means at each one of those pivotal
moments throughout the entirety of the
universe when thanos helps him defeat
the magus when thanos gives the magus a
false reality stone when each one of
those things takes place then it won't
happen and the future that's going to
come out of that is going to be a future
where the maggots will dominate all of
reality and put the kind of things that
thanos did during infinity gauntlet and
infinity war and infinity crusade and
the infinity siblings and all that kind
of stuff it'll put all that to shame and
so of course eros basically backs off
his actions and destroying thanos as a
baby and they essentially teleport back
to the modern day or 2018 at the time
this is being done to the base of where
eros is operating at and when the
question is what do we do here you know
if this plan of killing thanos is a baby
is not gonna work then what plan do you
have and adam warlock says this and he
kills he kills eros pip the troll begins
to freak out but the response of adam
warlock is according to the living
tribunal this is the only thing that's
going to work and so what we do is we
basically jump back to the future with
with thanos who's essentially absorbed
all these various cosmic entities and
this this you know we'll call him like
primitive thanos more or less in
comparison to his like ultra powerful
future counterpart but primitive thanos
is met by the arrival of eternity and he
was told by his future version eternity
and infinity are really a couple of the
last stops that you have before this
entire thing is is taken care of right
before it's all done and so what this
does is it leads to a conflict between
the two now the cool thing about this
and i love how jim sterling plays on
this thanos this is not his first time
up to back he's done this dance he's
played this game he understands the the
significance of eternity and infinity
the power that they wield but thanos is
not concerned about either of them
because the power he possesses in the
form of the astral regulator is way
beyond the power of of infinity and
eternity and so where they show up here
and they basically start using their
various abilities to try to destroy
thanos we jump back to eros and eros of
course having been killed in the modern
day ends up traveling to the realm of
mistress death because at the time that
he died thanos had not killed and
absorbed mistress death yet and so what
it meant is that basically being there
mistress death is aware of the plot that
thanos has in his attempt to like
basically show up on her doorstep and
kill her at some future point in time
which kind of makes sense being a cosmic
entity that understands the notions of
like life and death and things like that
it makes sense that she would be aware
of that and so with that being the case
she believes eros is there as a spy and
so in order to resolve the situation she
vanishes eros from her realm that action
right there is what saves all things in
existence like that action right there
is why eros is so important and that's
why adam warlock killed him it's because
that one thing is going to essentially
be the saving grace or at least i assume
it is right and so transitioning back to
thanos facing off against eternity and
an infinity the reality is they're
really more pomp and circumstance here
than anything anything else they're
blowing a bunch of hot air that for all
their talk of like you're going to fall
we're going to destroy you all that kind
of stuff it's really just more pride
than anything else and the face of the
astral regulator and the power that it
represents and the face of all these
vaunted abilities that he has infinity
and eternity fall and it's kind of crazy
because the conflict between the two of
them basically spans like all things in
existence right it expands all of time
and space across the universe itself all
time across the universe like everything
across the entirety of the universe is
felt by them from the universe's very
beginnings all the way to its very end
the point at which it dies like this is
what we're talking about here this is
the kind of level of power that we're
discussing because that's what these
characters represent infinity represents
time and eternity represents space and
so to fight them is to fight all of time
and space and so that's why these these
conflicts between these beings literally
have shock waves across the entirety of
the universe's history and the space the
universe occupies it's like being able
to witness an explosion all at the same
time right so like there's like an
atomic bomb that goes off or some kind
of explosion doesn't matter what it is
but like you see it and then a person
from 500 years ago sees the exact same
explosion and a person in a thousand
years sees the exact same explosion some
kind of an event across all time and
space i know it's super meta and i know
it seems kind of kind of crazy and a
little mind bending but that's what
we're talking about when we're talking
about cosmic entities but regardless of
how hard they fight and regardless of
what tricks they pull up their sleeve in
the sense of infinity manipulating time
and trying to like age thanos and you
know try to destroy thanos and the
collapse of his physical form and all
that kind of stuff none of it works and
the two of them are absorbed into
themselves and when that happens thanos
is confronted with the with the living
tribunal and the living tribunal
basically appears here and says this
cannot be allowed to stand this amount
of power that you have what you've done
it's created an incredible imbalance in
the universe itself more so than that
you threaten the entirety of the
multiverse there's nothing to negotiate
here there's nothing for us to talk
about you thanos are going to have to
fall and so what we do is we jump back
to eros and so eros resurrecting
basically coming back from the dead
having been banished from mistress death
this is what the living tribunal was
referring to by being outside the norm
that adam warlock can never die adam
warlock will live forever he will always
resurrect no matter how you kill him no
matter what means it is that he's his
physical body is destroyed somebody
somewhere will be walking and like
they'll die they'll just kill over from
a heart attack or they'll be hit by a
bus and they'll be used as a method by
which adam warlock returns thanos has
been banished from the realm of mistress
death he was banished from her realm
long before this story took place right
he was banned he can never ever die like
now eros is the exact same way they
exist outside the norm because they're
immutable forces now right they're not
really on par with cosmic entities and
so far he's like they're all powerful
it's not really that way it's simply the
natural order of things which is things
are born and things die and then there's
them they're outside the norm they're
outside the natural order and so that's
the reason why why eros is so important
here is because with him and adam
warlock working together presumably they
should be able to defeat thanos and so
following this we pick up basically with
this massive destruction you know this
massive explosion seemingly in the
entirety of this system and the defeat
of the living tribunal and that's why
this is important is because when you
think of a fight between the living
tribunal and you think of the living
tribunal's destruction most likely you
think of hickman's avengers and new
avengers because that's really the only
time that we ever saw that happening
like the only time we saw before that
was during marvel the end and it was
really more of thanos absorbing all of
reality into himself and then recreating
it again usually when you think of like
an extremely powerful being like the
living tribunal being destroyed you
think of like this massive explosion of
energy that would just shatter the
entirety of the multiverse it's like
it's like it's like grabbing a brick and
just throwing it into a into a glass
house right it's just it's gonna shatter
the entire thing right it's gonna it's
gonna destroy some part of the glass
house and the rest of it's gonna
collapse under its own weight that's
kind of how you you assume that
situation to be the way this plays out
though is again it's basically just this
idea of thanos absorbing the living
tribunal into himself but that's what
thanos is now at this moment right now
thanos has absorbed the living tribunal
into himself or at least that seems to
be the case now things are gonna be
explained a little bit more at a future
point in time but like thanos basically
jumps in with his future counterpart
like starts talking to him and
essentially his future counterpart says
you are now where i am right like we are
now where we're supposed to be you have
achieved the level of power i wanted you
to achieve we are now one and literally
they merge into a singular being right
now this is just jim starlin's way of
rectifying the time stream the future
version of thanos got modern-day thanos
to this level of power and the two of
them are now occupying the same space at
the same time the truth is that they're
a singular being right they're the same
person both cannot exist at the same
time and so they basically become the
singular person and when that happens
thanos says now the real game begins now
i thanos whom essentially the sum total
of all of reality will go forward and i
will face off against the one above all
okay so we are getting into infinity
ending and here's the funny thing i
initially planned on waiting until like
next week to start this but you guys
have been screaming at me when we
covered infinity conflict to start the
next part
so i was like okay i mean i don't really
see a reason not to but there's a couple
things i do want to explain here because
there was a little bit of uh uncertainty
that i noticed in the comments section
some of you guys seemed a little unsure
and so the way this has played out so
far is we essentially had like two
versions of thanos right we had present
day thanos and then we had future thanos
and the future thanos had somehow found
a way to essentially absorb all these
various cosmic entities right everybody
from localized and smaller cosmic
entities like mistress death or eternity
or infinity all the way up to like the
living tribunal and so initially the
question was why is he working with his
younger self and the idea was that he
was guiding present-day thanos through a
series of steps to ensure his own
survival right to ensure that he would
become the person he became with regards
to future thanos and so the result of
this is that from there the question was
okay then if there's something standing
in his path then why doesn't he stop
that and this really came into play with
the death of eros and the nature of adam
warlock in the sense that as we talked
about in the last video adam warlock is
essentially immortal he'll always come
back right no matter how he dies and no
matter how much time passes he'll always
return this basically placed adam
warlock outside of the norm because he
does not abide by the normal rules of
life and death when eros was killed by
adam warlock adam warlock had hoped that
mistress death would banish eros from
her realm for whatever reason either
because she understood adam warlock's
goal in killing him or because she
believed that euros was going to be
working alongside thanos to basically
usurp her role whatever the reason was
we knew that it was because she was
afraid that eros was working alongside
thanos she banished eros from her realm
and that in turn landed eros outside the
norm because he now no longer abides by
the normal rules of life and death he's
essentially immortal he can never really
die and so having said this what it did
is it led up to this massive battle that
was actually kind of a little bit of a
portion that seems a little murky here
we essentially had a scenario where
thanos had absorbed the living tribunal
into himself what makes this kind of
crazy is that as this comic picks up
we've got the one above all and then
you've got the living tribunal there
right so i don't know if this is some
kind of an error or if i misinterpreted
it you know however it was that happened
but literally in the preface of the book
like as you open it up and you know one
of the last things it says is like you
know present-day thanos has killed the
last embodiment the living tribunal
itself and merged with his despotic
future self right so like he absorbed
the living tribunal so the question is
how is the living tribunal here that's
really kind of how this is now at the
end of the day it doesn't really matter
because when this happens the one above
all basically tells thanos to stop right
to stop his actions and to in turn to go
back to his normal role and thanos says
no now the question that a lot of people
have here and that i noticed was a lot
of people were asking if the one above
all is this nigh omnipotent
indestructible and immutable force
inside the entirety of the marvel
multiverse then why doesn't it just will
thanos out of existence right there's
nothing the the one of all cannot do and
the reason why is because jim starlin is
basically altering the form and function
of the one above all and stories from
years past right old fantastic four
stories old sensational spider-man
stories the role of the one above all
was essentially kind of a prime mover in
the sense that like he created the first
universe we saw that in al ewing's
ultimate and then the first universe
basically fractured when the aspirins
and the celestials went to war and then
those fractured pieces created the first
multiverse and by whatever manner and
whatever means those different universes
came to an end and then were reborn
again but the one above all didn't
really sit back and then like create the
first multiverse and then every time a
universe dies he creates a new one he
just sort of set things in motion and
they went through whatever path they
went through but regardless of his
hands-on or lack of lack thereof his
hands on approach with the multiverse
the reality was there's nothing the one
above all cannot do he represents the
writers or the artists or stan lee or
jack kirby whichever depiction you want
to go with depending on which comic
you're reading at the time jim starlin
is basically modifying that and what he
says here is this idea that the the one
above all is actually not really a slave
to the structure of the multiverse but
he can't break its rules that the one
above all basically created all things
in existence and there are certain
safeguards there that not even the one
above all can can get past which really
kind of defies his purpose right it's
kind of like that that old school
quagmire can god create an object that's
too heavy for him to lift that's really
what this is right you know kind of this
idea of defying omnipotence and so
that's why it seems a little strange
because the one above all should be able
to just will thanos out of existence
that it should just kind of end that way
but the result is that when you're
invoking something like this you can't
right you can't on one hand bring in the
one above all and basically kind of
create a scenario where thanos faces off
against him in any believable way if
like the one above all is this immutable
and indestructible force that nothing
can stop and so what happens is over the
span of the first three pages the one
above all and and i guess the living
tribunal you know in this instance face
off against thanos and thanos
immediately absorbs them and so
essentially thanos has now become the
new one above all and that's the crazy
thing about this right it happens like
that in the blink of an eye and it's a
wild situation because you literally
have adam warlock and who have eros and
you have pip troll watching this whole
thing go down and when thanos re-emerges
thanos is now all things in existence
from that point going forward they bail
eeros grabs pip the troll he grabs adam
warlock with the intention of
teleporting away adam warlock yanks his
hand away eros and pit patrol are gone
and adam warlock remains behind and
talking to thanos you know the new one
above all we kind of get this
explanation right this sort of
explanation in terms of what he can do
and so on and so forth now what's also
interesting is he points out this notion
that because of the fact that adam
warlock and eros exist outside of the of
the norm fifth thanos while he can
detect them has to work hard to do it
right they're not just easily
perceptible to him it's almost like it's
almost like trying to detect a dark grey
amidst a black background right it's
possible you just really have to be
looking for it and so because of that
adam warlock one immediately picks up on
that and then two you end up having
thanos who basically pulls adam warlock
into himself with the purpose of always
being able to locate adam warlock right
to kind of remove that aspect and then
from there thanos starts to mute and
this is normal for for jim starlin it's
actually one of the things that always
made his handling of thanos so cool the
way he would write thanos was really
more of he would see himself almost kind
of like in a philosophical way right he
would he would kind of muse about these
things he says now i am linked to all
there is right he's not actually i mean
he is all there is but he's linked into
everything right everything from the
past and the present throughout every
single universe that exists and it's
almost overwhelming right it's almost
overwhelming for thanos to sit down and
say all actualities all realities that
exist out there every universe that
exists in the entirety of the multiverse
i am all those things this is a whole
new level of power that's way beyond
anything thanos has ever had before the
closest he ever got to this was during
marvel the end when he absorbed the
multiverse into himself and then brought
it back with death basically being
permanent meaning nobody could be
resurrected again it was kind of a
criticism of marvel in this sense that
they always killed and brought back
people and to basically kind of remove
that or try to make it in continuity
marvel ultimately said no because they
like being able to kill people and then
bring them back later it makes for good
click bait storytelling what it does
show here is really kind of the role of
the one above all in terms of all the
various forms that it exists in and when
it comes to the one above all in marvel
it's one of these things where like it's
it's marvel's version of the presence
from dc and the presence is like dc's
version of the one above all right and
what i mean by that is what you have
inside of of the comic book landscape
you have a singular universe then you
have stuff like an oververse or you have
an underverse so on and so forth but the
the the broad broad strokes here that
you have a singular universe then you
have a multiverse and then you have
what's called the omniverse and the way
this works is that a universe is a
universe right it's just a singular
universe that you occupy the main marvel
universe the ultimate universe the
marvel cinematic universe those those
different universes make up the entirety
of the multiverse the omniverse is
composed of all things in existence
right so there's the marvel multiverse
and the dc multiverse and the spawn
multiverse and like like any concept
that exists out there is part of the
greater omniverse and marvel's one above
all is kind of a guy who oversees all
that right it's marvel's god above all
gods essentially so it's it's one of
these things where they all kind of
cross over and all gets really weird and
it's not really designed to say that
like the one above all is over the
presence it's marvel kind of saying i
mean our version is and then dc is like
no our version is and spawn's like no no
no you're both wrong our version is so
it's
it's kind of one of these things where
it just sort of goes around but thanos
is basically tapping into and overseeing
everything across every single universe
and every single multiverse on every
single property that exists in the world
belonging to anybody regardless of
whoever made it that's how far-reaching
this is and so it gets kind of crazy
here because with that being the case
heroes kind of picks up on the notion of
what we talked about already that thanos
cannot easily recognize him because he's
outside the norm thanos has to hunt for
him as hard as he possibly can right a
needle in a stack of needles is really
what this is and so with that being the
case because pip the troll is
essentially viewed as thanos as one of
the people out there who can throw a
wrench in the works then what eros does
is basically tear up a backpack more or
less and then put the troll inside of it
so that pip the troll is as close to
heroes as he can possibly be and by
extension of eros being outside the norm
that will hopefully kind of permeate to
fit the troll now it really kind of
seems to be this idea that it's not
really like an ero shaped hole in the
universe if that makes sense almost kind
of like a permeation of like this energy
that makes him outside the norm that
hopefully will also encompass uh
encompass pip the troll that kind of
seems to be what he's shooting for and
jim sterling plays it fast and loose we
don't really get any definitive answers
there but we're kind of more or less
left to believe that is actually the
case and so what ends up happening is is
eros and patrol basically say okay fine
then let's see what's going on let's see
if we can find a way to defeat thanos in
the past or whatever it is kind of
throwing out these various macguffins
here and you end up having heroes and
pip the trolls show up on the ship of
thanos which is currently occupied by
corvus glaive and proxima midnight but
then they vanish they disappear and eros
figures out this is happening because
what thanos is doing is getting rid of
anybody who knows his plan and who could
potentially find a way to take him out
that's what's so cool about this is
thanos is just kind of getting rid of
people here and there but this is the
one thing to understand here and this is
this is awesome the way jim starlin does
it thanos is handling his omnipotence
and his power the way a mortal person
would thanos is not handling his
abilities the way the one above all
would and there's a huge distinction
there and we'll find out what that
distinction is as we get through this
video but from there you pick up with
adam warlock who basically emerges after
having been ensnared by thanos with
thanos ability to see him and
essentially locates kane the conqueror
now again kane the conqueror was from a
previous infinity story but it was by
virtue of cain the conqueror that eeros
managed to attain his time traveling
technology as well as a few other things
going on but what this means is that
using the ability of kang to manipulate
time adam warlock seemingly has some bit
of an out and so from here we jump to
one of the most important parts of the
story when we pick up with present-day
thanos and present-day thanos his
consciousness is basically inside the
mind of future thanos right like this
version of thanos that merged with the
one above all and all that kind of stuff
that's future thanos who's done all that
present day thanos is just kind of a
consciousness that's along for the ride
and it's cool when he basically talks
about this right he says things like yes
i'm still here like you know i was i was
basically press gained into this
situation but what it shows is that
their ideologies are not entirely linked
present-day thanos is not fully on board
with what future thanos is doing right
he knows his plan he knows what he wants
to achieve but even for modern day
thanos that seems pretty extreme and
that says something right given whatever
this future plan or whatever this plan
of future thanos is if present-day
thanos looks at that and says yeah man
like that's pretty crazy man like that's
pretty extreme that means it's really
got to be something right because we're
talking about a guy who got a hold of
the infinity gauntlet and wiped out half
the life in the universe just to impress
a girl right so like it's kind of crazy
like it's kind of nuts you know in terms
of this this whole thing going but what
it also shows here and really what he
what he basically tells us is that the
amount of energy and the amount of focus
necessary to be able to handle this much
power while it's within the abilities of
future thanos to contain these abilities
it's a whole other thing to understand
how to use them effectively and so what
this means is that future thanos is
still figuring out what it is that he
can do he hasn't fully been able to
channel the totality of the one above
all's power now this is important
because what it means is that it
presents this idea that maybe even the
one above all was limited by its own
imagination and that if thanos can
essentially break free of those
limitations then his power would
transcend the previous one above all's
power the reality of this is that what
future thanos is doing is hunting around
for eros it's the thing that's
dominating his mind and the reason why
is because heroes will in some form or
fashion find a way to basically defeat
future thanos right like eros could find
a way to defeat his brother it's
possibly only a matter of time before
thanos loses this power of the one above
all so again it's super cool it's a guy
with the power of god who hasn't quite
figured out how to use it all yet and so
from there you basically pick up with
eros who's like okay one he asks isaac
the sentient computer right before it's
destroyed by future thanos if he can
figure out a way to calculate when the
universe is going to end and they're
able to you know he's able to basically
draw you know kind of create an
algorithm you know in the blink of an
eye like super advanced you know other
worldly computers do and then
essentially calculate when the universe
is going to end and when eros and pip
the troll are teleported there it's just
a giant empty canvas and then future
thanos simply says let there be an end
in essence thanos destroys himself the
idea behind this and this is what's
really important here the idea behind
this is that thanos you know with with
these limitations that were created by
the one above all the indication is that
thanos is still bound by those and so
what this really seems to point out is
that the future version of thanos his
goal after having basically defeated
eros and ensuring that nobody can be in
his way is to basically wipe out
everything in existence and then
recreate it as himself being the one
above all he's wiping the board clean
and starting over again it removes any
of the limitations that were created by
the previous one above all and thanos is
free to recreate all the multiverse and
the omniverse as he sees fit and that's
what's so wild here it's because what we
do from there is where heroes and pip
the troll are essentially dispelled from
that future and sent back to the modern
day what it does you know because of the
fact that they cannot die right so like
they're just kicked back to the modern
day what it does is it picks up with
cain the conqueror and adam warlock
having a discussion with each other and
kane the conqueror not really wanting to
essentially admits that what you know
the kind of field that he's on right now
with thanos attaining the power of the
one above all with the actions of adam
warlock things like that these are way
beyond what kang is normally used to and
the reality is he's basically being
reduced to a guy who can just help adam
warlock out as best he can despite all
the intelligence and all the time
traveling abilities of kang he's way out
of his element here more so than that
adam warlock throws in this idea and
really kind of gives us some this
amazing notion that future thanos
operating with all this power again has
not figured out how to use it and in the
time that he could be taking to figure
out how to use it instead he's taking
that time to focus on finding eros this
makes him vulnerable this is basically
just a really really really powerful
thanos and that's why we don't really
have an instance where it's like why
didn't you just go back to the very
beginnings of time and stop eros from
being born if thanos went back in time
and killed eros at birth then perhaps
future thanos never exists it is really
kind of bound by the rules of time right
the rules of time travel time
manipulation different things like that
and so what we end up doing is picking
up with adam warlock right adam warlock
basically trying to find a particular
access point within the cosmos basically
an access point that will allow him to
enter the psyche of future thanos right
because he's undetectable or at least it
seemed to be that way and then like
entering the future psyche of thanos and
then in turn you know just kind of
getting a better understanding of what's
going on now the reason why adam warlock
is able to do this is not because he's
undetectable that's my mistake he is
right the the reason why adam warlock
can do this is because adam warlock is
part and partial to thanos and so thanos
won't really feel it is like an ant
biting him or anything like that he'll
just kind of see it as the normal
comings and goings of the multiverse and
how things function and so on and so
forth and because his attention is off
of adam warlock because he believes that
adam warlock is now a negated factor
right he's not anything to really worry
about instead with him focusing on eros
at least adam warlock opened to invade
the psyche of thanos because he's just
not paying attention but before adam
warlock can do that he's suddenly met by
the arrival of an unexpected character
okay so we are picking back up again
with the infinity ending and we're
actually we're ending the infinity
ending
i thought about titling that infinity
ending ending
seemed kind of weird but in the last
video we basically left off with the
idea that adam warlock was essentially
met out of nowhere by a person that i
kind of left you guys on a cliffhanger
on and the reality is it's not actually
a person but a group of people it's
pretty much all the versions of adam
warlock from the past and the funny
thing about this is this goes all the
way back to him right the guy who's not
wearing anything but underwear that's
how adam warlock first appeared when he
was in marvel comics and it's just
different iterations of his character as
time has gone on and the funny thing
about this is that adam warlock has
historically been a guy where his
understanding of the the cosmos and the
multiverse has kind of been really
beyond most other people even the cosmic
entities themselves right it's the
reason why thanos wanted him to become
the new living tribunal when we were
reading one of the older infinity
stories but when you when you get into
this what you end up having is this
scenario where these versions of adam
really kind of say no like
self-preservation is more important than
the universe and there's a couple of
reasons why they're coming from this
perspective the first is because they're
sentient beings right it's just the
nature of us as people we care about
ourselves more than we care about other
things right it's just the way that we
are and so what we also have here is the
notion that adam warlock can never truly
die and so no matter no matter what
happens in this universe where it ends
or where it returns adam warlock will
essentially always end up returning and
his other selves sort of recognize this
right but the idea of adam warlock and
this really kind of seems to be an
ideology for his character that's
changed over the years but the ideology
of adam warlock at this point in time is
saving the universe is the most
important thing and in reality it's not
as though they're killing off an entire
universe of people it's quite the
opposite defeat one guy in order to save
all of creation right it's classic
utilitarianism the needs of the many
outweigh the needs of the few and so
it's a cool perception here's a cool
notion here because adam warlock has
been without his soul gym for quite some
time now the reality is adam warlock
doesn't really need the soul gym i mean
it kind of helps to bolster his power a
bit but he never really needed it i mean
he's exceedingly powerful even without
the gem but what he ends up doing with
these various guys these various
versions of themselves is basically
snatching the soul gem off of one of
their heads and then essentially
overpowering all the others now we don't
really know exactly what happens to them
but regardless of the situation the
result is that adam warlock ends up
coming out on top and so following this
he basically dives through a portal and
into the consciousness of thanos now
this is not the first time this has
happened they've been inside each
other's minds before in the subconscious
mind of adam warlock it's all about
death and rebirth right people riding an
elevator all the way up to the top of
this cliff more or less falling off
dying and then getting back up and doing
it all over again the cycle of death and
rebirth constantly taking place with
thanos it was just nihilism reign
supreme right just just death and
destruction and so adam kind of dives
into the mind of the one above all
thanos that we're talking about now and
the funny thing about this is that each
one of these places that he sees is now
an entire universe unto itself adam
warlock is hopping from one universe to
the next within the mind of one above
all thanos but that's more or less
what's going on here one of the first
memories he sees or one of the first
things he sees is thanos as a little kid
who basically breaks a lamp now the
funny thing about this is we can look at
this a couple different ways right we
can look at this story as being out of
continuity or we can look at the story
being incontinuity and the reason why is
because sui-san's currently there for
those of you guys who read the rise and
fall of thanos i think it was i think it
was ed rubaker or jason aaron one of
those two who wrote it we basically got
the life and times of thanos right all
the events that led to him in
encountering mistress death for the very
first time and then going forward and
becoming the villain that we that we all
know and love in the early days sweet
son and when i say early days i mean
like almost immediately after giving
birth but srisan tried to kill thanos
because she saw him as a bad omen and
had a vision that his actions would lead
to the downfall and the destructions of
everybody on titan which it did and so
she tried to take him out and ultimately
she was thrown in a mental institution
and so if this story is in continuity at
the time the thanos is this age suisan
should be in a mental institution but
she's not she's there so that kind of
leads us to believe that either it was
jim sterling kind of trying to correct
things and saying no no this is how it
should be or it's not in continuity but
the other funny thing that kind of comes
out of this is eros and pip the troll
now remember these are two guys and
while they're not necessarily bungling
buffoons they certainly don't have any
real kind of concrete plan right their
plan here to try to stop future thanos
from acquiring all this insane power
capturing his modern day self and then
going on to become the one above all
their whole attempt to basically stop
that is to convince thanos that he's a
good guy that he's cool you know and
that like eros loves him and that's
basically it right like words don't win
conflicts more or less and so because of
that we end up kind of jumping through
these different moments and thanos's
life and you kind of have thanos when
he's relatively young when he's you know
kind of going through that that age of
of bodies changing and puberty and he's
kind of put on a few pounds
you know and drinking a soda it looks
like and eros tries to convince thanos
like he's a cool guy you know the thanos
is great that eros loves him and it is
really heroes like trying to convince
thanos of this right the next time they
appear is when thanos is feeding some
bullies to some monsters in a cave
because the bullies needed to understand
their place in the bigger picture
following that like is thanos basically
launching an attack and destroying the
entire planet planet of titan all these
different things that are going on with
thanos committing these action as this
is going on we have two versions of
thanos here that's one thing to keep in
mind we've got essentially what amounts
to present day thanos or the easiest way
to think about it and then we've got
future thanos and if you guys recall in
the last video we talked about this
right future thanos was the one that was
trying to attain the power to become the
one above all present day thanos is the
one who was being used in order to
follow in those footsteps and assure
that that path was actually followed and
once present-day thanos went through all
those steps then he was absorbed by
future thanos to ensure that nothing
would ever go wrong and that's why you
see this version of thanos was sort of
hovering in a tank this is present-day
thanos being held prisoner by his future
self and so eros and then basically
arriving to what's actually thanos first
appearance in marvel comics when he
fought iron man in terms of his
chronological appearances we have them
showing up in instances like during the
events of infinity gauntlet these really
cool little moments here and there and
it's one of these things where present
day thanos kind of says okay like i can
reach out basically psychically and i
can communicate with them right i can
talk to them through my past self
basically and that's what you see
playing out here right like eros and
those guys will show up to a particular
point in time and then thanos will talk
to them and as they basically kind of
run over their plan but they only get
brief moments right they only get these
really really small moments and the
reason why this is kind of being held
off the reason why these moments are
only ever so short is because present
day thanos realizes that if they stop
and they talk for too long it'll create
abnormalities in the time stream that
his future version will become aware of
and then start tracing them down and
ultimately realizing what it is that
eeros and pip the troll are trying to do
now at the end of the day again it
doesn't really matter they're not
actually doing anything uh but it is
kind of a cool little effort right it's
a cool attempt one of the other funny
things to come out of this is that
because of all these paradoxes and all
these shifts that eras and pip patrol
are making they end up showing up at a
future point in time and we have the
cosmic entities but they're different
this right here actually doesn't really
make any sense and the reason why is if
you understand the nature of cosmic
entities they exist in two forms right
they exist in their true form which is
an abstract form it has no true physical
form right they're just an ideology if
you had like the desire to go get
something to eat it would be like if
that desire to eat could get up and walk
around right that thought that concept
could get up and move that's what a
cosmic entity is now when cosmic
entities appear in a physical form they
go to the dimension of manifestations
and they basically receive a form from
anthropomorpho and then they show up in
the main marvel universe in a physical
form but it's just one of these these
these small little things right so you
know it's it's a it's a cool little
moment it's a little a little wonky and
a little crazy but again that's kind of
what we're dealing with here are sort of
these escapades of jumping back and
forth through time and so when eros is
talking to present-day thanos when they
say like like i guess we can work
together and eros is very much unsure
about this because it's trusting a guy
who's well known for betrayal thanos is
kind of like at the end of the day our
goals are basically mutual here at the
end of the day like we're trying to
achieve the same goal i'm currently
trapped in the essence more or less of
my future self come there rescue me and
then like we'll save the day and the
cool thing about that is that when that
happens when eros shows up it's not
really eero saving thanos instead eros
is seemingly kind of whisked away eros
just sort of says like this isn't right
this isn't how it's supposed to be and
he just ends up taking off adam warlock
peeps his head in to see what eros is
doing while he's on his journey and then
basically you know once once that
happens adam warlock kind of pops back
in or at least sort of disappears for a
second when future thanos shows up and
the reason why this matters is because
future thanos as we know was looking for
eros not to kill him or to capture him
but because with eros existing outside
of life and death then it was basically
impossible for one above all thanos to
track him down now again this is jim
starlin shifting things around this is
jim starlin changing things under normal
circumstances and everything up to this
point it's not how the one above all
worked everything that is is the one
above all the face that you see when it
speaks to things is no different than
eternity popping up and then like
talking to somebody right it's just the
entirety of the omniverse and all things
coalescing in the form of a face that
can have a conversation with you with
that being the case anything even if
it's outside the realm of life and death
is still part of the one above all if it
exists if it talks if it's if it's
anything that can be drawn or written it
exists as part of the one above all so
again jim sterling is kind of shifting
things up and saying that's not
necessarily the case here right like you
know anything that exists outside of
life and death meaning it can't truly
die it's outside the one above all's
purview because it's considered an
anomaly right which is kind of crazy to
sort of limit the power of the one above
all and a lot of you guys were making
comments about that you were saying like
well i guess now he's just the one above
most is what it is
and you're not wrong right you're not
entirely wrong the one above pretty much
most things unless the plot calls for
him to not be above things like that's
basically what it is you know and so
it's it's kind of wild here but with
eros having popped up and basically
shown up in the essence of future thanos
to rescue present-day thanos by default
he made himself part of future thanos
therefore everything is now complete
right future thanos has attained his
goal of tracking down eros and basically
making eros a part of himself even if it
was only because eros just sort of
walked into it right so it's essentially
thanos was trying to get eros into a
house and eros just sort of wandered in
there on his own that's really kind of
what this is right now when future
thanos basically leaves adam warlock
then pops up and that's when present day
thanos is like you have to free me from
this prison but the the response of adam
warlock is no i'm not going to do that
you have to trust me here you need to
stay here this is all part of my plan
now thanos initially sort of questions
it and isn't really sure but the reality
is that adam warlock is kind of a master
planner it's one of these things where
when adam warlock comes up with a plan
it's not really to be questioned the
issue with this is we're talking about
uncharted territory it's one thing to
create a plan just have thanos lose the
infinity gauntlet because he gets
carried away with himself and because
warlock understands thanos's
subconscious mind and how he thinks it's
another to form a plan against a
seemingly nigh omnipotent being that
cannot truly be destroyed by anybody
here or really anything in existence
right so you know like i have a plan to
defeat a being that cannot be defeated
that's kind of what that what that sort
of comes down to and it's a little wild
there because what adam warlock ends up
doing is basically watching all of this
go down right the idea was okay let's
let this play out and let's see what
happens it's a dangerous gambit because
this could fail in in the most
spectacular sense but future thanos ends
up doing what he intended to do he ends
up wiping away all of reality now we
didn't know what the motivation was
before but we currently do now and the
idea is that future thanos looks around
and is almost kind of agreeable in terms
of what it is that he's doing and why
he's doing it right at the end of the
day he kind of makes this argument
between utilitarianism and deontological
ethics the intentions versus actions
let's say for example that like you see
a homeless man and you give that
homeless man five bucks right your idea
is to just give that guy five bucks to
help him along his way but what if in
reality by giving him that five dollars
all you've done is make him a target for
somebody else because he didn't earn
that five dollars he doesn't know how to
keep it and because he didn't know how
to keep it either he's swindled by
somebody who dupes him out of it or he's
not physically capable of holding it on
his own somebody beats him up and then
takes it would he have died had you not
given him that five dollars that's the
philosophical quandary that we're
talking about here and depending on what
philosophical viewpoint you come from
whether you're at fault or not begins to
shift if we say the only thing that
matters is intention right that's the
only thing that really matters here is
intention then at the end of the day
it's like then your intention was to
make that guy's life better and that's
where your responsibility stops right
that's where it ends as far as you're
concerned you did what you thought was a
good thing done right we're we're
finished there from there then it starts
going into things like okay if all that
matters is action then you gave that guy
five dollars but then you also cost him
his life and so is your act moral well
you know that's the kind of issue that
you run into here and so it's one of
these things where thanos really kind of
looks at it and says the only thing that
really matters in this universe matters
in this world is actions right what
people's intentions are don't matter
what matters are deeds and that
everything is just a giant contest right
even the cosmic entities seek to be
supreme over the other in some form or
fashion despite the fact that they're
designed to be immutable despite the
fact that they're designed to be these
forces that that represent ideas and
they don't really seek to better one
another at the end of the day there's
still a kind of contest there and so
thanos's response is then we'll recreate
things loyalty was conceived to deceive
people trust is a fantasy for fools and
is basically played upon by scoundrels
who look to exploit it the universe as
it exists now is one of naivety it's
people who believe they can change the
universe and so on by just doing good
things or believing good things but at
the end of the day like it's a screwed
up and terrible place this seems to be
like the core perspective of thanos and
so with that being the case he says okay
then let's recreate everything and so
with that going down you know with that
happening the way that it does you know
he basically goes to essentially
recreate all of existence and it offers
this momentary gambit right when you
have adam warlock who's essentially
outside the existing multiverse watching
it all go down right once he retreats
outside of thanos and kind of goes back
to this outside the multiverse kind of
space then in turn like once future
thanos wipes everything out of existence
and then seems to recreate everything we
kind of get this brief moment where
present day thanos basically says okay
now's a chance to actually do something
i get this brief moment to basically
take this action and then basically adam
warlock just kind of wakes up in the
void without any real indication of
where he is or where he's at he's just
kind of out in this total oblivion of
absolute nothingness and the indication
is that he's totally outside of all
recreated existence the omniverse as it
exists he's way out there to give you
perspective this is more or less just
stories that have not been told yet and
so with him being out there out in the
void out in the nothingness there's no
stars no planets no nothing just
infinite blackness but he ends up
getting this kind of lifeline that comes
through a sort of portal where he's
basically yanked forward by kane the
conqueror and that was the idea was to
to really have kang basically grab eros
and pick the troll to ensure they stayed
alive adam warlock didn't quite know
what would happen to him but the more
important thing was to ensure that
everything was saved and the plan
basically went as he expected that in
this moment of vulnerability in this
moment where future thanos had basically
dispersed his energy or attempted to
disperse his energy present-day thanos
basically sees that power for himself
that after seizing all that power of the
one above all from his future
counterpart because of the fact that
present day thanos never really agreed
with his future counterpart his future
version ceased to exist just by virtue
of destroying his essence more or less
and then present-day thanos used the
power of the one above all to reset
everything back to normal and this is
where the story totally falls short and
the reason why is because we don't see
any of that happen it's all explained to
adam warlock by kane the conqueror who
watched it all go down right so adam
warlock wasn't even really a part of it
he wasn't a part of seeing everything
recreated and all that kind of stuff
some will probably say well we didn't
need to see that others will say
something something something jim
starlin higher plane of reasoning who
knows but whatever the case is it's
basically one of these things where like
we missed out on what could have been a
really really cool appearance of a story
or some exposition and some explanation
there in terms of like why thanos did
what he did in terms of like from his
perspective because we know why he did
what he did and we get the exposition
it's just from some time traveling guy
that makes stories overly complicated
and so it's like okay that's kind of
weird and so they kind of make a final
stop and adam warlock of course again
still in possession of the soul stone
presents the the reality stone to thanos
and the truth and this is kind of the
important thing here the truth is that
it's entirely possible that his future
self could get carried away with power
again and the entire process could
repeat itself but it's one of these
things where adam warlock trusts thanos
right he trusts the character of thanos
to do what needs to be done not only
that but basically we kind of have this
this sort of assumption that we have to
make that if present-day thanos did take
the power of the one above all from his
future counterpart and then set
everything back that he may have just
kind of walked the time stream just find
out exactly what went wrong or where he
kind of lived through the time stream so
he knows the mistakes that he made and
we kind of have to assume that like if
he did set everything back he's aware of
of himself or he's aware of like what he
would what he would become or something
like that it's not clearly explained
it's not clearly defined and i think
that's kind of one of the issues here it
sort of leaves things pretty ambiguous
right and it really feels like the
ending in the story was wrapped up super
fast right it was just wrapped up very
very quickly and it sort of left a bit
to be desired but at the end of the day
things just kind of go back to the way
they were before right everything just
sort of goes back to normal and then you
kind of have adam warlock who's just
sort of sitting there in a bar you know
out in or really in starland's bar is
what they call it jim someone named a
bar after himself but he's just kind of
sitting in a bar and just sort of
chilling there and people kind of have
this concern that things are not
necessarily going back for the better
but at the end of the day we won't truly
know as far as i'm aware this is the
last of the infinity stories that jim
starlin's writing of course i think
infinity finale was also supposed to be
the last one and then it wasn't but at
the end of the day this is really where
it just kind of wraps up so with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and i will catch
you all later
peace